j'accueille rémy bricka
[Musique]
c'est la cool tiens voilà le marchand de
ballons et d aider
lehmann
c'est là en cours il faut sortir et en
profiter tes péchés
on va trouver
c
le monde
dépêchez vous
non
m
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
rémy bricka en plein footing matinal
dans le parc monceau au coeur de paris
en juillet trois fois par semaine de
courir ici fait trois tours ici après je
refais encore deux kilomètres qui me
fait sept kilomètres donc ça fait un
demi marathon par semaine au minimum
et en vrai sportif il rentre même chez
lui en courant
à peine rentré dans son appartement on
découvre une autre passion de rémy qui
recouvre tous les murs la vie je voulais
être pas et puis c'est la musique
qui a pris le dessus et là c'est un peu
un retour en arrière mais première
passion donc je me suis mis à peindre
énormément en huit ans et puis là je me
suis remis quand même dans la dans la
musique puisque c'est mon métier c'est
c'est par là que j'apporte du bonheur
aux gens
et du bonheur il en apporte dans toute
l'europe où il se produit encore et
enchaîne les dates je vais faire un
festival bientôt en espagne à segovia
donc j'ai encore quelque chose sont
adaptées en espagnol
cindy ses mains a dominé malades week
end face à bienne
enquête a raté
une répétition sous l'oeil bienveillant
de sa femme marie rose partenaires de
chaque instant on est très
complémentaires je pense et c'est ça qui
fait kiffer la longévité de notre amour
suis inquiet à la lumière et l'autre qui
qui est plutôt en coulisses
allez direction l'atelier pour accorder
quelques instruments
alors ici c'est une sorte de caverne
d'ali baba où il ya vraiment du tout
l'instrument des tas de débit de choses
que j'essaye je vais coller à l'agrément
de plus
il ya tout ici c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire toutes sortes d'instruments un peu
bruyant
des oeuvres venues de l'imagination d'un
savant un peu fou mais toujours
organisés j'essaye toujours de faire une
chose à la fois et lorsque lorsqu'un
projet terminé bajeux je pense à l'autre
c'est le secret du bonheur c'est de
s'amuser da curiosity permet justement
de rester jeune le plus longtemps
possible
d'ailleurs moi je programme jusqu'à son
temps au moins
voilà je crois que fut bien il a fait le
tour
ben on va voir eric vincent donc c'est
un ami que j'ai car vu que j'ai vu que
récemment de 40 ans que j'avais pas vu
donc ça me fait vraiment plaisir de le
revoir et on s'est retrouvés grâce à un
réseau social
un ami qui partage ses deux passions la
musique et la mer
j'ai bien vu ça va et bienvenus
bon alors c'est par l'alors
aurait fait attention au mas au oui
voilà ça c'est tous les pays que tu as
fait
quand en me disant content de retrouver
les amis qui
ils sont toujours en pleine forme
et quand il s'agit de la mer sa
traversée de l'atlantique revient
toujours à la team impressionne tu
m'impressionnes team a quand même
fortement impressionné avec ses records
que tu as fait entre en marchant sur les
eaux d'abord de marcher sur l'eau oui
c'est vrai toi tu la fais ça c'est
formidable baccouche se prêterait mes
skis comme jeter par à marcher là
quel sera donc le prochain défi de cet
homme plein de surprises
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
rémy bricka rémy bienvenue sur plateau
tout le monde a parlé vous êtes né le 10
avril 1949 à niederbronn les bains dans
le nord de l'alsace vous êtes l'aîné de
huit frères et soeurs en france pas très
heureuse à reichshoffen père maçon votre
mère lily est une femme assez violente
et c'est volage et elle est plus prompte
à distribuer les coups que les câlins
qu'elle garde pour d'autres comme
will tell me refuser son amour
bah j'ai toujours cherché son amour et
puis c'est jamais venu ouais
mais bon c'est comme ça il ne pouvait
pas se partager entre autres et ses
enfants et puis
ces hommes ouais
alors le premier exutoire sera le sport
vous devenez un bon gymnastes comme
votre père et puis un excellent coureur
en fait vous rêvez d'être artiste
peintre mais après l'école primaire on
vous inscrire dans une formation
d'ajusteur à bischwiller c'est dur pour
vous oui parce que quand l'alsacien on
dit ça ne finira 2 signifie dessinateur
mon malheur à ma mère avait compris des
sénateurs industriels et moi j'avais
compris peintre d'art
donc au bout d'un an et demi j'ai
bifurqué jeu devenu acheteur est ce qui
m'a permis ça vous a permis de d'y
ajuster une quinzaine d'instruments de
musique sur vous et de devenir l'homme
orchestre est vite j'ai créé un monde à
moi pour tromper ma solitude je voulais
m'échapper de la réalité tout simplement
et je me suis fait un monde de rêve un
monde imaginaire
alors vous avez 20 ans quand vous
débarquez à paris en 1969 nous
travailler comme employée de bureau mais
vous caressez toujours le rêve de
réussir dans la chanson et vous fait
l'homme orchestre à la terrasse des
cafés et dans les coûts de cinéma et
c'est comme ça que vous fait remarqué
par un producteur devant les locaux du
journal le monde s'est passé comment
mais j'avais une ancienne amie qui qui
sortait plus avec vous à ce moment là
elle sortait avec un producteur 1 et
l a amenée sur les grands boulevards et
puis m'a dit
je vois que dans la rue tu es le
meilleur même et je peux faire quelque
chose de mieux avec toi voilà où on a
une chanson pour toi qu'on a écrite
spécialement pour toi alors c'est chez
mireille au petit conservatoire de la
chanson que vous faites votre première
apparition à la télévision n'était pas
commode mirail 1 je suis arrivé en
retard à une répétition
ce que ce france inter à ce moment là et
elle m'a dit ben vous passez pas ce soir
et moi qu'est ce que je fais je suis
rentrée en plein milieu de la soirée
l'enregistrement elle n'a pas apprécié
way était très dur alors deuxième
apparition à la télévision le réveillon
1971 chez philippe bouvard l'émission
samedi soir enregistré chez maxim's
voilà ça a été plus facile
hossa a été bien parce que c'était mou
tout premier disque qui s'appelait pour
en dollars pour un pénis et en chantant
sur les trottoirs que je gagne ma vie
alors à ce moment là philippe bouvard
amedi bon ben vous faites à la fin de la
chanson vous fait la quête 1 et puis
quand j'ai regardé matisse et billes je
me suis dit mais c'est bizarre il met
moins d'argent que dans la rue
aurait été le le comble c'est qu'à la
fin il ya un des postiers là qu'est
venue à et me dit vous permettez que je
reprenne ma monnaie donc je me suis dit
ah c'est pas pareil que dans la vie à la
télévision c'est un monde à part ça
c'est vrai alors effectivement en 1972
vous sortez votre premier 45 tours pour
un penny pour un dollar chez decca avant
de vous produire sur le paquebot france
pour la première traversée
de la rue je passais directement en
première classe sur le paquebot et je
comprenais pas en plus ça il y à il ya
une personne qui travaille pour un
passager donc c'est un monde
complètement pour moi irréel surtout
après avoir garé ma petite mobylette
entre les rôles séché devant chez maxim
somme faisait tout drôle quoi alors en
1976 deuxième 45 tours la vie en
couleurs chez polydor ah ça marche très
très bien vous êtes disques d'or et en
plus de ça c'était avec une chanson qui
était destiné à claude françois et qu'il
avait refusé
pour moi
alors 1977 premier album le succès
devient international vous travaillez en
allemagne en espagne en amérique du sud
et même au japon tu enregistres deux 45
tours en japonais phonétique oui j'ai
appris quelques mots quand même ouais ça
va racheter une rolls quand même un
ouais bah c'est mon rêve d'enfant tout
ça vraiment parce que issu d'une famille
pauvre en réalité ce qu on appelle ça
une famille pauvre je me suis dit je
vais essayer de revenir avec une rolls à
la maison mais ça me correspondait pas
parce que près de chez moi dans le paris
17ème là quand je passais mes voeux dans
le marché les gens me disaient sales
capitalistes
après je me suis acheté une une cx six
roues pour et là c'est bon faisait des
envieux 1 mais pas d'en bas dans le côté
jaloux ouais voilà c'est les gens
étaient admiratifs devant ces sept
voitures customisées à mes couleurs et
rémy bricka qui existe toujours
d'ailleurs qui roule toujours alors vous
devenu une vraie star de la télévision
quelle a été la réaction de votre
entourage comme ça a marché comme ça
pour vous mon père a malheureusement a
été décédé entre temps et ma mère et mes
frères et soeurs était fier au contraire
à l'école par tous
d'un seul coup d'un seul coup c'est
j'étais devenu une référence en alsace
voilà un rémy bricka c'est un enfant du
pays d'un seul coup qui a réussi à paris
et ça c'est plutôt flatteur comment
c'était les relations avec les médias la
presse la radio la télévision on sait
bien je me souviens d'un article dans le
monde où il comparait les hommes
politiques le président sarkozy a même
été comparées en homme-orchestre dans la
rubrique à
gagner de l'argent beaucoup d'argent
mais ouais je gagnais beaucoup d'argent
que je n'ai pas su garder avant non
parce que
on avait toujours manqué chez nous un
peu de tout donc d'un seul coup mais je
me retrouvais plein d'argent et aussi
avec plein d'habits
et plein d'amis qui avaient besoin
d'argent non moi je ne comptais pas trop
alors j'avais ça fait plusieurs voitures
je dépends cgt pense et j'avais des
appartements droite à gauche mais
toujours en location donc sa rentrée ça
sortait voilà pas thésauriser quoi pas
du tout ben je ne
je pensais que ça allait durer toujours
donc c'est ce qu'on pense toujours
et l'amour ça a dû vous rapporter pas
mal de conquêtes non ce succès oui mais
ça m'a pas fait bouger les choses moi je
me souviens seulement une fois j'étais
avec c'était avant que j'achète ma rolls
j'étais en mobylette parce que voilà
j'ai vu je transportais mais à ce moment
de musique toujours avec une petite
remorque derrière le mil est devant et
j'étais passé la république et puis un
moment les deux filles qui ne va assez
vite rica sera médical puis moi je
filais effet les je voudrais pas que me
voir je me suis dit je suis pas la
hauteur j'étais un peu en décalage donc
après je me suis rendu compte qu'à
chaque fois je faisais des spectacles
j'entendais fille qui triait
bon moi j'étais j'étais calme bon après
ça s'est heureusement calme et donc
voilà vous n'avez jamais profiter mais
normalement quel a été le meilleur
moment de cette époque ça a été le
meilleur moment c'est apporter du
bonheur aux gens ça c'est sûr que ce
rêve que les enfants au et que les gens
osent se perdent ce père noël sont peu
dire
il ya tout il ya les colombiens les
fusées il ya cet art respecte
un vrai spectacle vous tout seul quel a
été le pire moment de cette époque je
crois je commençais vraiment à voir une
carrière nationale devait travailler
avec les membres de ma famille et qui
ont peu fait péricliter qui ont fait
dérailler ma carrière internationale
et ça je le regrette un petit peu oui
effectivement je crois qu'il vaut mieux
éviter de travail et de la famille parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas capables de faire
ce que vous leur demandiez de fer en
fait oui voila voila je l'aurais donné
leur confiance c'est un petit peu mon
défaut c'est que j'ai toujours un petit
peu trop aider les gens chaque fois
qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui avait besoin
de quelque chose ou une copine qui
voulait réussir dans la chanson c'est
moi qui paye et les photos qu'ils paient
ce site est payé tout pour finalement
puis je me suis un peu oublié ces petits
mots je le regrette parce que je pense
que dans ce métier là il faut être faut
être égoïste donc maintenant je suis
plus calme plus zen mais je pense plus
au sia morin parce que finalement
j'étais une sorte de locomotive mais à
force de tirer les wagons et la
locomotive commence freiner freiner
justement au milieu des années 80 ouais
votre carrière faibli et là vous
découvrez une autre passion la mer
l'homme orchestre va devenir l'homme qui
marche sur l'eau extraordinaire d'avoir
rebondi à ce point là vous réalisez
grâce à vos skis flotteurs propulsé par
deux rames des parcours absolument
incroyable londres paris donc en passant
dans la tamise la mer du nord les canaux
l'oise et la seine voilà c'est quand
même extraordinaire vous faites kahn
qu'elle vit et où fait la traversée de
l'atlantique
je voulais la faire un peu comme faisait
à la bombe art sans eau ni livre ouais
mais comment ça vous est venue cette
idée jamais personne n'avait fait ça non
plus après ma traversée qui a duré deux
mois
j'ai fait de quelques conférences et
puis un moment donné le maître
conférencier m'a dit j'ai dit j'ai
marché sur la mer me disent se recréer
le maire avait beau marché met donc
c'était sûrement psychanalytique c'est
lacanien oui la cagne absolument mais
vous échouerez votre traversée du
pacifique si vous voulez faire los
angeles sydney comme à ses singles et
aussi comme truc 14,8 km 14 mai c'est
incroyable et là vous passez 153 jours
seul sur l'océan vous manqués mourir
deux fois à cause des requins ça a été
épouvantable
mais j'ai déjà eu un temps très
difficiles des tempêtes
effroyable les cyclones et j'ai tout eu
j'ai eu du vent contraire le matériel à
casser
ça a été vraiment vraiment très très dur
et mais j'ai tenu à chaque fois que vous
tombez il ya les requins qui arrive
c'est surtout les petits requins qui
sont dangereux mon année j'ai rien ce
qui ma foi les la jambe
je suis passé vraiment près de la mort
plusieurs fois mais et en plus de ça
j'avais un téléphone satellite et la
société a failli
[Rires]
à oui mais vraiment c'est une femme
extraordinaire s'appelle marie rosé qui
a monté une expédition avec toute une
équipe de thalassa et qu'il y avait des
vrais baroudeurs ton jo le guen un degré
qui a également échoué dans sur le
pacifique à la rame tous avaient échoué
d'ailleurs toutes les traversées avait
échoué y avait eu cinq tentatives la
même année al ahram lesquels quatre
premières aient pu me la mienne sur les
skis donc effectivement j'ai pas été
surpris ils ont repêché puis voilà sont
repêchés en plein milieu à 850 km au sud
rail alors l'échec de cette tentative
sera finalement une grande réussite pour
vous parce que en fait ces 153 jours
vous avez passées sur l'eau du pacifique
vous sert un petit peu de retraite une
retraite bénéfique vous entamez à ce
moment là une recherche personnelle et
spirituelle
spirituel oui par la force des choses
parce que lorsque on est cinq mois tout
seul avec soi même si téléphone qui
marche pendant quatre mois on est quand
même seul malgré tout et j'ai souvent
effectivement pu parler avec avec
d'autres voies mais bon c'est difficile
à expliquer pour quelqu'un qui était
rien d'ailleurs je dirais que lorsqu'on
est tout seul confronté à à rien que du
vent que la nature que des poissons
volants
des oiseaux quelques oiseaux qui passait
quand même
on a forcément d'autres d'autres
contacts avec un avec avec les éléments
et puis après la recherche personnelle
est venue après oui prime a traversé
ensuite fait ces temps de l'analyse et
vous comprenez à ce moment là que votre
enfance très douloureuse évidemment à
cause de votre mère vous a toujours
amené à vouloir vous faire aimer des
autres
d'abord avec la chanson et ensuite avec
les exploits et là vous finissez par
comprendre qu'ils vous êtes déjà j'ai
osé traverser la rue parce qu'en face de
chez moi il y avait les beaux-arts de la
ville de paris où il y avait des cours
de peinture donc je suis revenu à
première passion j'ai osé ce verset
voilà je suis passé par le passé fixé
travers la voilà et donc là je me suis
mis à peindre pendant
j'irai de 2002 admis
un petit peu à 2010 énormément j'ai tout
est sortie c'était une vraie une vraie
thérapie pour moi et puis je me suis je
commencé à m'aimer à des hauts lieux
d'aimer les autres je me suis commencé à
ses débuts mais vous avez une expression
formidable vous dites j'ai trouvé mon
pacifique intérieur c'est se pacifier
par par le pacifique qui ne qui lui
n'était pas passée fut pas du tout
vous dites tout le reste n'est que
vanité
j'aimerais un magnifique parcours vous
avez aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique
de l'époque de la vie en couleurs
non parce que la vie en couleurs ll dur
tous les jours oui ça va je suis
beaucoup demander effectivement donc si
on me voit un peu moins c'est pas vrai
c'est pas grave l'important c'est que je
ne vis pas à travers la télé je vis à
travers mon art
si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous
ne referiez pas pareil dans votre vie
rémi je crois que je serais plus égoïste
je je j'irai droit au but ouais voilà
c'est à dire quelque part lorsqu'on
arrive de bas
au contraire au lieu d'avoir des
chevilles qui enflent et toussaint qui
triomphe le moi je suis raide je suis
l'indien je suis resté un indien je suis
pas devenu cowboys voilà mais maintenant
je dirais que j'ai appris un truc
cowboys maintenant
le jour vous allez mourir qu'elle
voulait qu'on écrive sur votre tombe moi
je préfère qu à la place de la tombe il
y ait des des fleurs qui poussent des
arbres qui poussent fruitiers de
préférence et
je mourrai donc à la manière des indiens
d'amérique et j'aimerais bien qu'il soit
marqué ce mot nude que l'homme orchestre
persister qui vivent toujours on sait
très bien c'est très heureux de rallumer
la lumière ça aurait mis vraiment merci
les corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il mettait un peu de
bleu